the mustang machi is half suv
half sports car and fully electric it
has a range of between 270 to over 300
miles depending on the version
consumer reports jonathan lincove says
the maquis also scores well in road
tests and safety so all that really
combines into a very impressive first
year electric vehicle the mustang with a
44 thousand dollar base price is one of
10 vehicles that make this year's top
list picks are based on several
categories including reliability and
performance they also have to have key
safety features such as forward
collision warning and automatic
emergency braking with pedestrian
detection standard those features can be
found on the toyota rav4 prime a hybrid
with a base price of 40 thousand dollars
the kia tunnel ride starts at 33
thousand dollars and is a top pick for
the third year in a row it received an
almost perfect score on the road test
it's had high owner satisfaction
according to our annual auto survey
other vehicles under 35 thousand include
the subaru forester which makes consumer
reports lists for the ninth year and the
toyota prius is a perennial top pick two
nissans are in the under 25 000 category
the sentra and rogue sport come standard
with the latest safety features both
vehicles have been very reliable for
consumers who have a need for speed
linkover says the mustang can go zero to
60 in around five seconds upgraded
versions are even faster elise preston
cbs news inglewood cliffs new jersey